hey guys Gina and Dave we are back at
Roseanne's kitchen table and Gina you
brought up something that I think is uh
is kind of interesting and uh oh thanks
AO to everything going on in the world
these days what do you got for me you
know I just I'm we're so overwhelmed
between I don't know the cable news
shows and the local news shows and pop
up YouTube channels everywhere and all
this stuff if everybody just please
don't mock YouTube channel I will mock
it because I will mock it all and that's
what we we they're there because people
want to give their opinion
Ops
culture opinion ands it do yeah and I
can't stop thinking about this because I
take that stuff really personally as I'm
sure you do as people who kind of are
forced to give their opinions a lot of
times right so we're in the biz I
suppose of giving our opinions but even
for us yeah not exactly kind of maybe
sometimes uh but even for us I always
feel like I have to have an opinion on
everything even things that I don't want
to have an opinion on so for example
last week with all this Cosby stuff I
did a video on it even though as I said
in the video the guy is my hero I want
to reserve judgment I don't want to
convict the guy in the court of public
opinion like everybody else is doing
before it goes down it's such a terrible
story and it's conjecture and blah blah
blah and it's like I still felt like if
I didn't say something then that's
saying something so then I did say
something and when I finished saying it
I was like H I feel kind of gross I
think everyone silkwood shower
afterwards yeah but I think a lot of
people have that people that are not
even doing the public thing the people
that are just constantly putting stuff
up on on Twitter and Facebook that
everyone feels like they have to say
something about everything I think it's
just kind of an interesting place for
humans to be at and is it that they feel
like they have to or they feel like it's
just safe I mean if I'm lying in bed and
I'm the only one there and I'm going
through Twitter Scrolls and I'm seeing
you know comedians make jokes at other
celebrities expense I'm know well it's
okay for him to do it 140 you said hold
on one second right and that actually as
I get older I've veered farther and
farther away from that because it's and
I don't mean to sound like I oh whatever
I just have to say it for me personally
I am now cool with the fact that I don't
want to put that out into the world for
me for me so you don't want to jump in
on the feeding frzy anymore so every
time a Cosby thing happens or a Paula
Dean thing or a Duck Dynasty guy or a
chick the thing on the other hand I mean
if somebody's done something wrong we're
allowed to say wait you have to answer
for that but just like crapping on
people just because we have access to a
camera it's I'm not into it and I think
that you're you know a classy dude that
does stuff in a classy way and and there
and there are others too that I respect
and like it's I feel safe giving my
opinion in because I don't think it's
going to be taken out of context but in
general like leave the judgment to other
people I'm not it just I don't I'm not
good at it I'm not comfortable standing
by those comments do you think there's
something to be said for people that
don't do any of this stuff like every
now and again I'll find I meet someone
that's like oh I'll be like oh well
what's your Twitter I'll follow you on
Twitter or something I'm not on Twitter
I have a friend visiting me this week
he's not on Twitter I don't even know
how to communicate with him you know
what I mean like that there are people
out there that actually aren't part of
this endless like opinion machine and
it's uh yeah and then I know somebody
that's truly Off the Grid like actually
with no electronic nothing like they
don't have an email address yeah haven't
heard from Social Security number you
have no idea they probably they always
end up living in the keys by the way
yeah that's when you really want to get
away from it all yeah that's the Jimmy
Buffet lifestyle it's pretty good yeah
but in general I just think that we've
become a culture that's just so used to
dumping on everybody else and if if you
want to do that great I'm afraid that
I'm going to do it and someone's going
to call me out on it and I'm going to go
oh you're right I didn't think that
through and that was just a really mean
stupid thing for me to say and if you
want to say it about me great but you
know what it's just not who I am yeah
well that was the thing with the Cosby
thing that was really killing me cuz I
had a couple really funny jokes related
to the show things that happened in the
show that I was able to put into Twitter
form and I was like oh even as I was
clicking it I was like don't do it and
then I did it and then it gets retweets
and then you feel that
affirmation well because that's another
thing because a very famous
well-respected comedian once told me if
it serves the comedy you got to do it I
know so that's that's another we're
slaves to Comedy people I really want to
know what you guys think on this one are
we giving opinions that we what that we
we Daren give Darren give or Darren
that's good that's
comment down below because your opinion
matters